the current state of Public Health is
horrific nearly 50% of adults have some
type of cardiovascular disease 10% of
adults have type 2 diabetes less than 7%
of adults are metabolically healthy wa
and these numbers represent individuals
they have real world consequences and a
lot of us are floating along with no
idea what's happening underneath the
hood we have great intentions we want to
be healthier but we're kind of throwing
darts at a a dartboard with the lights
off my core mission is to empower people
to use science to turn the lights on how
do you help us understand what this 12we
challenge will do for our
[Music]
health